not too far from Earth is a giant space
rock that has silently played host to
just twelve people in its entire history
what would happen if we put our cosmic
satellite to work by covering it with
solar panels what would it take to build
an enormous power plant on the moon how
big would this facility be and how much
time would it take to finish this mega
construction this is what if and here's
what would happen if we covered the moon
with solar panels because the moon has
little to no atmosphere there's no wind
no rain and no clouds on that space rock
if a lunar weather man were to tell you
the forecast it would always be the same
imagine how much energy we'd collect
from a place where the Sun never stops
shining but how would we even build a
solar plant on the moon one Japanese
company Shimizu already has that covered
they want to build a so called lunar
ring and yes it would look just the way
it sounds a ring of solar panels
spanning around the moon the
construction would stretch for 11,000
kilometres along the moon's equator and
would reach 400 kilometres and width
that's enough to cover half of the
United States where on earth would we
even find enough materials for
assembling this enormous solar plant
well the answer lies outside of our
planet's natural budget most of the
building materials would come from the
moon itself we'd only have to launch the
initial equipment over there just enough
to start building more equipment and
manufacturing lunar robots then a team
of robots together with a group of
astronauts would handle the rest
for starters they'd construct huge
excavator and ore processing machines to
mine the moon then
they begin assembling solar panels from
the lunar materials with nothing but
lunar soil and gravel they make concrete
ceramics and solar cells meanwhile
astronauts on earth would be working on
building space ports in low-earth orbit
to ship the remaining supplies like
hydrogen to the moon even with the most
advanced technology we can think of the
construction would take at least two
generations of humans to complete but
once it's done we'd have a super
efficient lunar power plant churning out
power 24/7 because there are no bad
weather days on the moon ever but what
about getting that power back to earth
well that's the fun part on the moon the
lunar power plant would transmit solar
power to the energy converting
facilities from there the converted
power would be beamed to power
collecting stations on earth with lasers
and microwaves how cool is that
potentially it could deliver so much
energy that we wouldn't need any other
power sources at all maybe building the
lunar power plant would happen at the
same time we constructed a human
occupied moon base that would one day
grow into a fully operational human
colony but that's a story for another
what-if
[Music]